hello everyone and welcome to Python
numpy tutorial video by simply Learn
Python is a versatile programming
language that allows you to perform
multiple tasks efficiently and
accurately one of Python's major utility
is in the field of data science and
analytics python is known for its simple
syntax and readability which is a major
benefit also the gentle learning curve
make it Stand Out Among old programming
languages with compiled syntax similarly
python has over 200 modules to help
developer reduce tasks and improve
efficiency one such module is the numpy
module in Python which is used almost
efficiently by every data professional
out there be data scientist or machine
learning engineer or data analyst it is
very important for an individual to
familiarize themselves with the
capabilities of this module and utilize
them in a day-to-day task as a data
professional with that being said
immerse yourself in the world of data
driven decision making through our
intensive data science bootcamp this
comprehensive program is tailored for
working professionals offering live
sessions led by esteem instructors from
Caltech engaging Capstone projects and
dedicated office hours to enhance your
learning experience enroll now for our
data science bootcamp where you will
gain a comprehensive understanding of
the course concepts of data science this
immersive program covers a wide range of
topics including Statics Python
Programming data analytics machine
learning deep learning neural language
processing data visualization tools and
much more to know more about the course
check out the course Link in the
description box below now let's jump on
to understanding what numpy module is in
Python but before that make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon for regular updates so let's
begin so last time we covered part one
where we went over the difference
between the python array and the numpy
array and why it's both easier to use
uses less memory and resources and is
also faster than the python list we also
went over a number of the basic features
in there by clicking up the Min the max
the median how you can go ahead and
create some very basic arrays fill them
all with zeros fill them all with ones
look up the size the shape so we covered
a lot we covered a range which is
equivalent of python well sort of the
equivalent of python list range and then
we looked a lot into characters working
with the NP character and how to
capitalize Center it change it to a
title lowercase uppercase splitting
stripping joining and replacing
characters so what's in it for you today
we're going to go over array
manipulation we're going to go over
numpy arithmetic operations slicing
arrays iterating over arrays array
concatenation splitting arrays numpy
histogram using matplot library and a
few other useful functions in the numpy
and then we'll do a practice examples at
the end and hopefully you've already got
your Jupiter notebook I like to use it
through Anaconda but certainly you just
use a direct Jupiter notebook let's go
ahead and dive in there since we're
going right into part two which is
getting some coding going under our belt
and here in our Jupiter notebook we can
go under new and create a new folder
python3 I think I forgot to do this last
time but we could just do the control
plus plus which in any browser enlarges
a page makes it a lot easier to see
always a nice feature another beautiful
benefit of using jupyter notebooks and
let me go ahead and show you a neat
thing we can do in Jupiter this is nice
if you're working with people and you're
doing this as a demo on a large screen
I'm going to do the hashtag or pound
symbol array manipulation kind of a
title that we're working on and then I'm
going to call this cell cell type
markdown as opposed to code and you'll
see it highlights it here and then if I
run it it just turns it into array
manipulation and then we're specifically
going to be working on array
manipulation changing shape to start
with and we'll go ahead and Mark this
cell also a markdown so has a nice
little look there and then it comes up
and you can see it just like I said it
just highlights it it makes it very bold
print just making it easier to read not
a python thing but a Jupiter thing is
good to know about especially if you're
working with the shareholders since
they're investing money in you of course
the first thing you want to do is import
we're going to import numpy
as in p and that should be standard by
now by now you you start a Python
program you're doing some data science
numpy is just something you bring in
there and let's go ahead and create our
array and we're going to do that as the
NP dot a range remember that's a zero
well we're going to do 0 to 9.
and then we'll print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is zero one two three four
five six seven eight and let's add a
print space in between
let's create a second array B but we
want this to reshape array a and what
does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if I did some weird numbers in
here it's not going to work
and we want multiples of nine we know
that three times three is nine so we're
going to reshape our a array by three by
three and then we're going to print
let's give it a title oops add too many
brackets in there modified array and
then let's go ahead and print
our B and let's see what that looks like
as we come down here you can see we've
taken this and it's gone from 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 to an array of arrays and we
have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. and so we split
this into three by three and you can
guess that if I tried to reshape this
let's just do a five by three which is
15. that's going to give me an error so
it's not going to work you're not going
to reshape something unless the shape
all the the data in there matches
correctly
so we can take this nine this flat 9 and
we call it a flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you might think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely I use it a lot in graphing
because they'll come in that I have an
array that's X Y comma X Y one white one
comma X2 Y2 and so the shape of it might
be 2 by the length of the number of
points and I need to separate that into
X flat array and a y flat array and you
can see this can be very easy to reshape
the array doing that and we can of
course go back we can do B
print and we'll do B dot platin remember
I said it's called a flatten array if we
run that you'll see it just goes back to
the original one it takes this zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
flattens it back to a single array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
F strangely enough F stands for Fortran
they hold fourtran days I remember
actually studying Fortran programming
language in this case you'll see that it
uses the first like it's zero three six
is the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight and if you go to the numpy array
page you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and D array flatten setup to look it up
and they have three different options
they have c f and a and it's whether to
flatten in C which was based on how the
C code works for flattening originally
worked which is row major the Fortran
which is column major or preserve the
column Fortran ordering from a so
whatever it was in the default is the C
version so the default that you saw you
could put orders equals c and it'd have
the same effect as we saw there before
you could even do order equals a that
would also have the same effect because
that's the default so really the only
other thing you really should change on
here is to change it to C if you need it
and you can see right here or F I mean
not C the only thing you really want to
change it to is to your f for the
Fortran order which then does it by
column versus by row and let's look at
here we go reshape so let's create a
range of 12
and let's reshape it
I will do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy I forgot the NP
there
NP dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course in
jupyter Notebook you even have a little
extra print at the beginning if we run
this we'll see we create a nice array of
0 1 2 it's reshaped it so we have four
rows and three columns or you could call
that three columns and four rows zero
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
but this one is so important we'll do NP
transpose
a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if I get all the s's in
there don't leave an S out and you'll
see here we've taken our array if you
remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 and we've swapped it so
we've gone from a three by four or a
four by three to a three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two and this is x y z well when
you go to plot it you send it all of X
in one array all of Y and I'm one array
and all Z in another array and so it's
really important that we can transpose
this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing I can
highlight it and do brackets around it
if you remember correctly
because we're in Jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if I hit the Run button it comes
up at the same exact thing and let's
play with the reshape and you don't want
to zoom this up a little bit here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
NP dot a range let's do eight
reshape
we'll do two comma four
let's go ahead and print B
and then run that and you'll see we have
now the two rows this is a bit more like
so we have four maybe two rows of four
things so this might be all of our X
components and our y components so we
can switch it back and forth real easy
important to note here whether we do two
comma four or in the case of four comma
three this has 12 elements and so
however you split it up it's got to
equal 12. so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's
pretty straightforward same thing down
here two times four equals eight if I
change this and let's say I do two comma
3 Let's just run that in and you'll find
we get an error because you can't split
8 up into two rows by three
we have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um
reshape or B again if I can type
reshape RB again and what else goes into
eight well we could do two by two by two
so we can take this out to three
different dimensions
and then of course if we um because this
is going to come out you as a variable
we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions so two by two by
two and let's go ahead and sign this to
a variable C equals B reshape and let's
do something a little different let's
roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our C do two comma one
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of zero
one two three four five six seven we now
have the zero two one three four six
five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with C comma one and run that and so
if we roll a single axis you get 0 1
and then it rolled the four five up and
then we have two three six seven and if
we do two let me see what happens there
and this is one of those things you
really have to play with and start
filling what it's doing
we've now taken zero two four six one
three five seven so you can see we've
now rolled by two digits instead of
rolling the one set up we now rolled two
digits up there and so if we go back and
we do the one
so we've rolled it up zero one four five
and then we're going to take the two in
there and we've rolled the 0 1 2 3 4 5
and 6 7. so we start rolling these
things around on here there's a lot of
different things you can do on this
what's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your uh numpy
and finally let's go ahead and swap
axes we'll do c and let's just go ahead
and run that it's going to error on
there
that's because it requires a multiple
arguments lift up the arguments so now
we can swap them we get the zero two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around
so next thing we want to go over is we
want to go over numpy arithmetic
operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right nice title
on there that's always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do a is an EP NP
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and it should
all look pretty familiar we have our
zero one two three four five six seven
eight on there and let's create a second
one B okay this time instead of doing a
range let's do NP array we'll just
create a straight up array
but we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be three by one and if
we go ahead and print a b out let me run
that this is actually pretty common to
have something like this where you have
a three by whatever it is in a three by
by three array when you're doing your
math you kind of have that kind of setup
on there and what we can do is we can go
um NP dot add
a b don't forget we can always put a
print statement on there so if we add it
you'll see that it just comes in there
and it goes okay we're adding 10 to
everything and we could actually do
something more I'll make it more
interesting 11 10 11 12. so it's chains
B's now 10 11 12 and let's run that
and you can see that we have 10 and then
you had one plus 11 is 12 2 plus 12 is
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on we'll put
this back since that's how the original
setup was let's do 10 by 10 by 10 and
run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b
and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect so we have our
subtraction 0 minus 10 is minus 10 and
so on and if you're going to add and
subtract you can guess what the next one
is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got 0 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
what's the last one we got is divide
what happens when we do divide a by B
and we run this
we're going to get 0 and this is 0
divided by 10 is 0 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on so the math is pretty
straightforward it just makes it very
easy to do the whole setup and again if
we went this and let's say let's change
this up up here instead of 10 we do a
hundred
and make this a thousand there we go if
we run that and then we do the add you
can see we got 10 plus 100 plus a
thousand same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
and then you can also see the same thing
here with the Divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10. oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10. we'll just go ahead and
run these and get back to where we were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just be cell cell type markdown and you
run that of course it gives us a nice
looking slicing there and slicing means
we're just going to take sections of the
array so let's create an array in p a
range
let's just do 20.
and if you remember if we do a we have a
0 to 19.
and then we can do a and remember we can
always print these this can always be
put in a print but because I'm in
Jupiter if you're doing a demo in
Jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we could slice four on and this should
look familiar because this is the same
as a python and a lot of other different
scripting languages if we do four we go
0 1 2 3 it's the first four in the thing
and the skip summon starts with this one
the first four are skipped then from
there on you can also do the opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get 0 1 2 3 quite the opposite
on there we can do a single item so we
can pick object number five on the list
run that and five happens to be five
because that's the order they're in and
then this one's interesting so I can do
s equals slice
and let's create a slice here and let's
do two comma nine comma
yeah let's leave a two on there so we'll
create an S Slice on here and then if we
take our array and we do array of s
we're taking our slice in there and
let's go ahead and run that and let's
take a look and see what it generated
here first off we started with two so we
have two at the beginning we're going to
end at 9 which happens to be eight so it
stops before the nine remember when
we're doing arrays in Python and then we
step two so two four six eight we could
do this as three let me run that and you
can see how that changes two five eight
and we could do this as let's leave this
at three and if we change this to 10
oops that's 12. there we go and we run
that we have 2 5 8 11. so that's pretty
straightforward it's a very nice feature
to have on here where you can slice it
and take different parts of the series
right out of the middle so now that
we've accessed the different pieces of
our array let's get into iterating
iteration and this is interesting
because my sister who runs a college
data science division
first question she asks
is how do you go through data and she's
asking can you do you know how to
iterate through data do you know how to
do a basic for Loop do you know how to
go through each piece of the data and in
numpy they have some cool controls for
that just sends a markdown there we go
and run it and it's called the ND itter
I'm sure what the ND stands for but
indeed iter for iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through we'll call it a equals
NP a range
let's do something a little funny here
or funky
and we'll do 0 45 5. I'm not sure why
the guys in the back pick this
particular one was kind of a fun one and
if I run that and we do this you can see
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and this is from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we create a slice of 0 45 0 to 45
step five let's see what we can do with
this we can also do a equals V shape
let's go ahead and take and reshape this
and since there's nine variables in
there we'll do a reshape at three by
three so if we run that oops missed
something there that is the a that
really helps so if we do the a reshape
and we'll go ahead and print that out we
get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. and then
we simply do four x in
our numpy in the enter
of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
X and let's see what happens here when
we run through this and we print each
one of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
so it prints out each object in the
array so you can go through and view
each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for a
and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the ND
iterator because it'll minimize the
amount of resources needed to go through
each of the different objects in the
numpy array
and hopefully you asked this question
when I just did that
and the question is how can I change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type Mark that down run it and so
we're going to work on iteration order C
style and F style remember C because it
came from the C programming and F
because it came from the old Fortran
programming so let's give us a reminder
I will do a print a and I'll do four x
and NP iterate a but we also want to do
this in a specific order and you know
what I'm a really lazy typer so let's go
back up here
this is the ND iterator I know I'm
missing the ND part of a let's do order
equals
C we'll print X on there and let's do
that again and this time order
equals
f
there we go order equals F and let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice is our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order C that's the default 0
5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see F order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each of the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
it goes into the second one 520 35 10 25
40. so slightly different order for
iterating through it if you need to do
that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
it's going to be joining arrays so we
need to bring them together let me go
ahead and take the cell and make it a
markdown
cell type markdown there we go and run
that so let's work on joining arrays so
we can bring them together and what
different options we have
and let's do we'll do an NP array one
two comma three four
we'll go ahead and print let's do oops
first
these Rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
so if we run this first array one two
three four whoops I forgot that it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way so we'll go ahead and keep it
separate
print a a there we go and let's go ahead
and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice I'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays depending on what
you're doing those shapes have to match
let's go ahead and print
second array
print
B I want to run that oops
I've missed something up there let me
fix that real quick
and I was reformatting it to go on
separate lines I messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four secondary five six
seven eight and we'll put a carried
return on there
and the keyword we use is um concatenate
and if you're familiar with Linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis zero so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight so now we have an array that
is four by two as a nice shape of four
by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis 0
you should guess what the next one is
we're going to do it along the one axes
and let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axes equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one remember a couple things one these
are the same shape so we have a two by
two same dimensions going in there
you're going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three three four five and let's
run that and if we come down here oh we
got there it says all the input rate
Dimensions except for the concatenation
axes M must match exactly so it'll let
you know if you mess up that's always a
good thing let's go ahead and take this
back here and let's go ahead and run
that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
we bring them together and you'll see a
very different setup here when we do it
along the axis one we end up with
instead of four by two we end up with a
two by four one two five six three four
seven eight and this is changing which
axes we're going to go ahead and
concatenate on what I find is when
you're talking about the concatenate or
the joining arrays you really got to
play with these for a while to make sure
you understand what you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually zero one two
three four five six seven eight axes one
is then splitting in a different way one
two five six three four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that under markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do NP split
we'll do a and we're going to split it
by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array 0 1 2 3 4
5 we get three separate arrays on here
now remember we're looking at let me
just print a up here
so we're looking at zero one two three
four five six seven eight and then we
can split it into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here let's move the a
split down here instead of the three
let's do four comma five and put that in
Brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three four five six seven eight
and that's kind of interesting I wasn't
sure what to expect on that but we get
when you split an a by four comma five
you get a totally different setup on
here as far as the way to split the
array
and to understand how this works I'm
going to change the five to a 7. and
this will visually make this a little
bit more clear
so we had four and five I went zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
you see the markers four and five when
we do four and seven I get zero one two
three four five six seven eight and so
what you're looking at here is the first
marker is this is going to go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four and then the second
split is going to be at position seven
and this is the same thing here four
position five that's why we're splitting
it in those two sections we could also
do it seven let's just see what that
looks like run and you can see I now
have zero one two three four five six
seven eight
so we can split in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of multiple arrays on here and split
it all kinds of different ways
before we get into the graphs and other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at resizing the
array I'm going to take the cell and set
the cells a markdown and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array an npro of one two three and
four five six here I'm just going to
just print
let's go print a DOT shape then we'll go
ahead and run that whoops hit a wrong
button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma 3 here and
this is important to note as we start
resizing it it's going to mess with
different aspects of the shape
and so I'm going to do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
NP dot resize
we're going to resize a
and let's resize it with three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print
B
and print the period shape not a comma
I'll run that
oops forgot the quotation marks around
the end we'll go ahead and run that and
let's just see what that looks like so
we have one two three four five six
original array with the shape of two
three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four five six and we end up
with the shape of three two that
shouldn't be too much of a surprise you
know we got six elements in there we can
resize it by two three was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so we
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing three two remember
last time I did the to reshape it I
messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error but when you resize it you
don't have to match the numbers they
don't have to be the same dimensions so
we can instead of going from a 2 3 to a
3 2 we can resize it to a 3 3. so let's
take a look and see how it handles that
and we come down here to 3 3 we end up
with one two three four five six and it
repeats one two three so it actually
takes the data and just adds a whole
other Block in there based on the
original data repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around
we want to go ahead and do is get a
little visual here because it um
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there but let's
look at the histogram let's put this
into a histogram let me go ahead and run
that
and to do that we're going to use the
matplot library so from matplot library
we're going to import pipelot as PLT
that's usually the notation you see for
pi plot so if you ever see PLT in a code
it's probably Pi plot in the matplot
library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me at 2087 4
40 53 with a bunch of numbers that way
we had something to play with and what
we want to do is we want to do uh plot
the histogram I remember a histogram
says how many times different numbers
come in and then we're going to put them
in bins and have been 0 to 20 to 40 to
60 to 80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
hear the term buckets or they put them
in buckets as a really common term then
we want to give it a title so the way it
works is you do your PLT to hist for
histogram your PLT title and your PLT
show and we're doing just a single array
in here in the numpy array of a and
let's go ahead and run this piece of
code
take it a moment to come out there's his
finger size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have and let's just
take a look at this and go down a size
there we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here so between 0 and
20 we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a four and a 11 and a 15.
zero one two three it's actually Four
values but they start at zeros remember
we always count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 142.
2 3 4
5 6.
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up is going to be between the 40
and 60 range least common when the 80
and 100 this looks like an age
demographics is what this looks like to
me and you can see where they would have
put it in the buckets of different age
groups which would be a nice way of
looking at this histograms are so
important and so powerful when you're
doing demos and explaining your data so
being able to quickly put a histogram up
that shows what's common and how it's
trending is really important and using
that with a numpy is really easy and you
know what let's take the same data and I
want to show you why we do bends or why
we have buckets of data I'm used to
calling it buckets why we have bins
let's do it instead of by 20 let's do it
by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one and on
the second one it looks like a ladder
going up and a plummet a letter going up
and a plummet and a ladder going down so
the first would be more indicative of an
age group and the second one would be
what she would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
Trend
um
I don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because I'm in 50 so I'm right in the
middle there which means I eat a ton of
food compared to everybody else but it's
some kind of democrat maybe it's mental
maybe it's knowledge because we we hit a
certain point then we start losing our
marbles start leaking out or something
so you start off knowing something and
then as you get older you grow more but
you can see here we lose that you lose
that continuity in the thing if you
split the histogram into too many bins
or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots on on the graph and
wouldn't mean a whole lot
and we've looked at graphs there turns
out there are a ton of useful functions
in numpy
I'm sure there's even new ones that are
aren't going to be in here but let's
just covers some important ones you
really need to know about if you're
using the numpy framework
one of them is Lane space function this
is generating data so you have a line
space we have one three ten and when we
do that we end up with 10 numbers so if
you count them there's 10 numbers
they're between 1 and 3 and they're
evenly spaced we get 1 1.222 but these
are all there's a total of 10 here and
it's right between the one and three
range
that could be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
array setup
a real common one is to do summation so
we'll do summation where you do in this
case we create an empty array of one of
two different arrays One Two Three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five and we're going to sum
them up under axes zero which is your
columns and if you remember correctly
columns is the one plus three two plus
four three plus five so we have three
columns and if we change this we'll just
flip this to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals twelve we'll set this back to
zero
there we go since it said it was just
looking at zero
and these probably could have been some
of these could be used to start math
section square root and standard
deviation two very important tools we
use throughout the machine learning
process and data science and simply we
take the NP array we have again the one
two three four five six three four five
I don't know I need to keep recreating
it I probably could have just kept it
but we can take the square root of a so
it goes through and it takes a square
root of all the different terms in a and
we can also take the standard deviation
how much they deviate in value on there
and there's a ravel function we can run
that
and NP array is X we're going to do x
equals a we change it from a to x x
equals Ravel and this sets it up as call
UPS so we have one two three four five
this is all columns on here very similar
to the flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also have the option of doing a
ravel by column and then another one is
log so you can do mathematical log on
your array in this case we have one two
three and we'll find the log base 10 for
each of those three numbers there's a
couple of them they don't you can't just
do any number here after log but there
is also log base 2. log base 10 is
pretty commonly used on here run that
there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have so let's do some numpy practice
examples and let's start by figuring out
how do you plot say a sine wave in numpy
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because I've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
NP and import our matplot library
pipelot as PLT so we get our tools going
here and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x Y
coordinates in here so first off let's
create our x coordinates and our x
coordinates we're going to set to an a
range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing sine and cosine it's going
to be between 0 and 0.1
and then we use our NP and we actually
can look up numpy stores Pi so you have
the option of just pulling Pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this and
just out of curiosity let's see what x
looks like I always like to do that so
we have
0.1.2.3.4 so we're going zero to in this
case 9.4 3 times numpy pi remember that
Pi is like three point something
something something that makes sense it
should be about nine and we're doing
intervals of 0.1 so we create a nice
range of data and then we need to create
our y variable and so Y is going to
Simply equal NP or numpy dot sine of X
and then once we have our X and Y and if
we print let's go and just print y see
all that we'll do this let's do this so
it looks print
X print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our X axes and our y
axes going on there
and this is simply a
plt.plot because we're going to plot the
points and we'll do X comma Y and then
we want to actually see the graph so
we'll do plot dot show and we'll go
ahead and run that and you see we get a
nice sine wave and here's our number 0
through 9 and here's our sine value
which oscillates between minus one and
one like we'd expect it to
then for the next challenge let's create
a six by six two dimensional array and
let one and zero be placed alternatively
across the diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six
two dimensional so the shape is six by
six two dimensional array and let one
and zero be placed alternatively across
the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to do
NP create a numpy zeros and we're going
to do a six by six and we'll go ahead
and make sure it knows it's an integer
even though it's usually the default and
just real quick let's take a look and
see what that looks like so if I run
this you can see I get six by six grid
so six by six zero zero zero zero zero
now if I understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals they
want the center diagonal maybe that's
going to stay zero all the way down
and then the next diagonal would be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones and
the next one zeros and so on hopefully
you can see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it so let's take a little
piece of code here
and we'll do Z One colon colon two comma
colon colon two equals one and wow
that's a mouthful right there so let's
go ahead and run this and see what
that's doing and so what we're doing is
we're saying hey let's look at in this
case Row one there's one and then we're
going to go every other row two so we're
going to skip a row so skip here skip
here skip here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns so you can see right here where
the that we're not touching each row is
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're going to start
with Row one and then we're going to
skip a row and another one and so we're
going every two rows and then in every
two rows we're looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means so we're going to
start with the beginning and we're going
to look at all of them but we're going
to skip every two so starting with Row
one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one Skip One
you know one Skip One One skip one one
if you lift this out and do every one
this would just be ones in fact let's
see what this looks like if I go like
this
and run it you can see that I guess get
ones
so this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row set up on there and
so if we're going to start with Row one
we also
control Z
try that there we go let's start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row and
this time we'll start with one column
one and again we go every other one
going down
step that's what that step two is
skipping every other one we're going to
set that equal to one so let's see what
that looks like and you can see here we
get our answer we get 0 1 1 0 0 but it
has the ones going in diagonals on every
other diagonal and zero on every other
one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step in your
different axis on there
and then the next one is find the total
number and locations of missing values
in the array the first challenge is to
create some missing numbers so let's
create our array Z we're going to do a
numpy DOT random dot Rand 10 comma ten
and before we do the second part let me
just take the second part out
now let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that and there we go so we
have a 10 by 10 random array it randomly
is picking out numbers
and next we want to go ahead and take
our random integer size equals 5. and
then we're going to do a random random
10 size equals 5. so in the Z we're
going to select a number of random
spaces here and set them equal to null
value
now let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like and if we
look at the array
we've created one two
three four this should be a fifth one in
here my eyes may be filling me so we've
created a series of oh because zero zero
to five zero one two three four so we
have there are different null values in
here and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates five by five miniature grid
inside of this to tell it where to put
the nands at so that's kind of a cool
little thing you can do
and we want to look up and see how many
null values are in there
and this is simply just NP is Nan of Z
simple so if it is nand then we want to
sum it up so we're going to sum up all
of the different null values on there
now let's do one one more feature in
here which is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
NP argue where NP is
Nan of Z so we're going to create our
own another NP array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes so we didn't count four
of them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time I
got five let's get for random numbers
another fun one that I always like to do
it's very similar is we have NP is nand
z dot sum so we're summing the number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes but you can also
just do we'll do an inds where NP is Nan
of Z
and let's just print let's print that
print inds let's see what that looks
like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three if I have split it into two
different arrays
so we have our X and our y kind of
coordinates going there and what I can
now do is I can now do z i n d s
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the well the numbers and
that kind of thing you have or the
average as it is so be one thing you
could do and you could pick up the
average that's very common in data
science to get the average and just use
that for a value
but we'll go ahead and just set it to
zero and then let's go ahead and print
our Z and run that and you can see we
come down here we have wherever there
was a null value it is now zero
and you could set this whatever you want
this is another way to replace data or
help clean data depending on what it is
you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so a
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flatten down there which remember we
have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by F
remember F stands for Fortran very
strange connotation but there's C and F
C as a standard and F switches it to a
different order
to be honest I usually have to look it
up because I almost never use f but when
you need it you're like oh my gosh it
was the other order just do a quick
Google so we talked about reshape making
sure that the dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to C 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four Oops
I did that the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about adding we talked
about subtracting multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions rounding
sums products differences there are so
many all these different miscellaneous
mathematical connotations so you know
Google it go to the main numpy page and
look at the different setups you can do
on there so we covered that and we did
slicing how to break it apart we did
iterating over the array we covered
joining arrays and how to concatenate
remember concatenate just means add-on
to it so in this case how are you adding
B onto a is how you'd read that from
Linux you should catch the concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in Array of arrays all
kinds of different ways to split the
array up how to resize it and remember
resize does not have to have the same
shape but if you resize it it will take
the data and begin at the beginning and
add new rows on if the size is bigger if
it's smaller it truncates it it just
cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned buying buckets or bins as
they call them in pi plot and then we
covered a lot of other useful functions
in numpy talked about the line space
setup for doing
um
numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median
all of those you can compute in numpy
and you can also do the square root and
standard deviation
the Ravel function very similar to the
flattened
to be honest I almost always just use
the flat but you know the Revel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your n value
which they did is three times pot and
then be pi and we're going to do
intervals of 0.1 and then y just equals
the numpy sine of x there's our math
from the math page we were just looking
at remember that's right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and Ones playing
with the different connotations of Z of
the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small sets of
data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that so with that we want to go ahead
and wrap this up and I want to thank you
for joining me today
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign